this song came along called uh all about
that bass you ever heard that oh yeah
so i took i heard that song and uh buddy
of mine we were riding
down the road and he goes because you
know she's talking about all about that
bass is
a reference to being thick so because
it's uh
that song's about being thick my buddy
looks over and he's a smaller guy
real small guy he looks over he says
you're actually all about that bass
and beard like that and i go you know
what i am i am thick and bearded
so i ended up writing a parody song
called all about that beard
to that song and we reproduced the whole
track
and i went and rented a camera didn't
know anything about really making music
videos
but i wanted to experiment so i rented
this camera
it was when the blackmagic cinema camera
first came out oh yeah yeah
and that was that first came out i
rented this camera and lens canon lens
whatever
and uh took this thing and
just did the best i could and i thought
well this i'll post this and
it it probably sucks and it does suck to
this day it sucks the video to me
but it literally got two million views
in a day
what two million views in a day yeah we
were my buddy and i were headed he had
an audition
at the time i lived in memphis um and my
buddy
brad beal a bill for councilman bill for
councilman bill
yeah brad beal was uh
he said he was an actor at the time and
he we were driving to nashville
for him to do an audition for some
commercial and he asked would i go with
my seat i'll go with you let's do it and
so
on the way i had posted that that
morning and on the way there
he's getting a few texts and i saw that
video you were in because he was in the
video
so i saw that video you were in
hilarious right and we're not thinking
nothing no he's like all right
right on man appreciate it and he gets a
few texts on the way there
and he and he i'm not getting any checks
but my people ain't seeing it you know
what i mean all right
so but apparently his people are all
seeing it but we did we didn't check the
video it wasn't it wasn't in the days
where i had
a reason to keep going to my facebook
all the time like now
i'm answering every comment that comes
in i'm doing all these things all the
time
making sure i stay on track because
those are my people you know
and so i didn't even have that facebook
or youtube both
okay well at the time like i got
i got uh my start on facebook on my
personal profile
oh okay yeah not youtube i wasn't even
really doing anything on youtube or my
facebook page
it was just a personal profile at the
time and that and it was just
like blowing up and we didn't even know
it we were just driving
he got a few texts he did his audition
on the way back he's still getting these
texts
as he was in his audition there was like
15 to 20 texts from people saying
hilarious video man that was crazy it's
crazy what's happening with this video
like that and then he goes dude
he said something something weird man he
said like everybody that i know has seen
this video
so he pulls it up as i'm driving he goes
bro
this thing is at 1.5 million views i
said
excuse me and i said let me see this
and i look at it and then jared this is
the first thing
jared and i did he just did uh he did
the
i don't want to say he did anything to
the video other than he just put credits
in it because i wanted credits in it
yeah and so i had jared put the credits
in
he's a little drunk yeah he got
pretty tore up last night you're still
drunk jared
really hey we hair the dog brother i got
some jack daniels right over there
hair hair the dog
no but he all he did was put credits at
the end like you know rolling credits
and uh he didn't shoot the video for you
no no
couldn't afford him uh and plus i was
trying to learn like a union
yeah he's union only only union no
i was trying to learn how to do it
myself anyway so it was kind of an
experimental thing
and uh anyway by the end of the day it
had two million views and i thought
now i really am famous right i was
getting calls to do radio interviews and
stuff like that
for in england and uh everywhere all
over the world i was like this is nuts
meghan trainor is fixing to call me and
we're gonna be doing a song together
that never happened i don't know if she
ever saw the video to this day
and now it has i don't know how he's got
it's got a lot of views on facebook
if you combine everything and on youtube
and everywhere it's it's
it's pretty good but uh so
at that point i'm thinking now i really
got to ride this wave yeah so i'm
i'm uh posting consistently at this
point and then but these
the other videos ain't getting two
million views you know what i mean
they're they're not doing it like the
that one did yeah that's the worst right
when you're like damn you hit so you hit
so high on one and then like keep doing
stuff and like [ __ ] why can't i do that
again
right and that's that's the conundrum
right that's the problem is
people think that oh as soon as you get
two million views everything you post is
about to be that
it's not the it's not the case it's all
because social media is fickle
the algorithm's fickle it's like you you
which i didn't know this at the time
you got a post at the right time you got
a you gotta
uh you can't put too many letters on
your on your images
on facebook you know there's a lot that
goes into it like there's
these algorithms is the the greatest
enemy of an independent artist or
independent anything
you know what i mean yeah so i'm being
consistent
and then i'm not so then three weeks go
by and i didn't post a video didn't post
a song
and so i'm thinking shoot man i said i'd
be consistent
and here i am letting bibi down you know
and uh
even though i didn't you know didn't
know bb but i felt like i did here i am
letting bibi down
and so you felt accountable to like you
held accountable yeah it was kind of it
was kind of like god's way of saying
bibi's going to hold you accountable and
uh so
at three o'clock in the morning three
weeks
of shadowing the fans i say fans i did
have some fans at this time
there was definitely people commenting
and i answered every comment
at that point and eve and even up until
like just a few years ago every single
comment was i answered like it don't
matter how many came in i answered them
now they're they're coming in on every
video and i don't get notifications for
these other videos so i can't answer
every comment anymore
but because you know if they don't
notify me i don't even know if they
commented
so but anyway i still get most of the
comments on the new videos
so three o'clock in the morning i'm
sitting there i'm like i don't have
i hadn't posted in a while i don't have
nothing because when i would when i
would
uh learn a song it would take me a while
to learn the song
because i'm not a guitar player you know
i'm just i would sit there to go over
and over and over and at the time there
was no teleprompters there was nothing
like that no kind of apps you could use
really that would help you wear with
lyrics even
so you just had to learn the song you
had to learn the lyrics and how to play
it and for me
that was real hard to do like just to be
able to memorize all the lyrics okay
okay i got it you talk about three or
four takes and then by the time you get
done
with ten takes your voice is shot and
you can't make the video
so what's not the easiest thing to do
when you if you don't
already know all the words like if a new
song comes out and you're trying to
learn it real quick
back then now if the new song comes out
you can pull up the lyrics and put it on
a little teleprompter thing that goes in
front of your camera
right and you look dead in the camera
and nobody even knows right
and then you're you're playing all you
got to focus on that point is just
just the chords which is still a
struggle for me i might miss a quarter
missed
manny last night um but
i said three o'clock in the morning it's
still my personal profile on my facebook
and uh i said i hadn't posted a video in
a while
i hope you all like this version of ice
sized baby that i did acoustic
it was literally like that throwaway
video and
the next morning this thing had went
wild
i mean it went nuts uh world star
hip-hop took it and posted it on their
pages
and their website uh bam margera
posted on his page and website and stuff
and this thing just
it got legs that never stopped and then
my facebook page started blowing up like
people started liking it out of this
world
youtube same thing and this thing like
my whole real actual career and music
began at that moment with that with that
cover that there was a throwaway
it was a throwaway video and it it still
to this day
if you combine every person that
actually took the video stole the video
from mine you know and then post it on
their own platforms
you're talking 200 plus million views
maybe wow
you know all together and uh there's
several
even on my page because i've posted it a
couple times too
and there's several on my page they have
30 plus million on just my my own page
of that one song that's nuts can you
monetize those videos when you do covers
like that
yeah really on youtube you can't you
can't well you can't on facebook now too
but
so youtube lets you monetize those even
though you're doing a cover
well the the difference is is i'm
recreating it
right i'm playing it oh that's me
playing i on that sound recording
okay so i make money on the sound
recording they still get their money
but you don't have like aren't you using
like their acapella or their uh
instrumentals no okay i'm playing my oh
you're
completely recreating it well especially
with eyesight's baby right
that's all me okay i got it but even if
i was just playing their exact chords
it's still me playing it i'm not using
an instrument is there a term for that
like interpolate or interpolation or
something like that
i don't know you're smart i'm not a
lawyer i'm a tow truck driver
you said it yourself right yeah i guess
you're right yeah if you're even if you
are playing just copying the chords and
recreating it yourself i guess they
can't
if you recreate a track yeah you own
that track you created okay
like that's your sound recording okay
now what happens with youtube
is you get money for the sound recording
part
they still claim their money for the
song right right
they still get part like they still have
claims on my my channel
but they can't they well they can they
could say you know we want you to take
that down they could do that if they
wanted to
but why would they they make money you
got to you got a video
i sized baby getting 100 million views
and we're
monetizing stuff like that you know
they're they want that to happen
because it's not it's not just doing
that it's helping with album sales and
things like that right
album record labels actually reach out
to me all the time now and when they got
a new artist and they'll say
you want to cover this artist's song
this song ain't out yet we want to
get i'm like no i don't want to cover
his song why would i cover that
i was like the only reason i cover songs
so people hear my originals
and i like if if i'm gonna cover a song
it's gotta have some
gotta have some weight to it mm-hmm
where else what's the point right you
know what i mean
or it's just a song that i love right
there's songs that i do that
that just mean something to me that's
other people's songs but
i'm not just out here trying to cover
some random song you know
because the goal is as an independent
artist that's my vehicle
to get people to hopefully check out the
originals right that's
all that is um so
lo and behold i'm getting all these
messages from people
because of this ice baby video i'm still
i'm still a tow truck driver as you said
right at this time i'm a tow truck
driver uh you feel like you know me my
whole life
um so
these people are messaging me and
they're saying
i'm best friends with vanilla ice give
me your phone number and i'll have him
reach out and i'm going
yeah right but i'm a tow truck driver
right so they can get my number anyway
glenn ray's towing it's available
everywhere and
so i gave it to all these people it was
probably
i don't know probably 10 10 to 15 people
said this and i gave them my phone
number
and it it so happened that one on one
lying one of them really was his best
friend
from way back before he was famous in
dallas you know he was
his best friend and uh so i get this
call randomly
i think it was around i think it was i
don't know how many months it was months
after this video
had come out and uh i'm horrible with
time frames
i get this call and i go glenn ray's
towing
you know like like normal it's a phone
call and he goes hey marty ray
like that and i said what's up
like glenn raised on you knew who it was
no i didn't know what it was i'm saying
i thought it was just a customer like
normal okay
and he goes he goes uh he says
man i love that ice size baby you did
that's nice man i said appreciate that
how can i help you you know what i mean
and he was like
hey it's rob it's rob man i go
right on man how can i help you
you know zach i didn't know i didn't i
hate to say this
you know i hope rob doesn't uh get
offended but i really didn't know his
name was rob
at the time yeah so i'm thinking okay
she's a customer
that somehow found out that i did this
song
and i'm like i got your car do i have
your car impounded like what is it
like how can i help you like thank you
for the compliment i appreciate it how
can i help you
he goes if it's vanilla ice i said
yeah right man like of course anybody
would you as a boy growing up
singing uh all right stop collaborate
and listen we're all singing that
growing well maybe not you because you
like hank
three yeah but uh you were probably
singing green day yeah
yeah the first green day album boom he
hit me with it
the dookie hit me with it i can't sing
it bro i'm not singing it